kristina is with us in Albany New York
hi Kristina how are you hi Dave good how
are you better than I deserve what's up
so I'm just getting ready to enter your
classes I took the first class on
Saturday and I'm hoping for some
encouragement because I'm really super
nervous that I'm not gonna be able to do
this one I've been responsible for my
family's finances since my husband and I
became engaged in 2007 and been managing
everything since then it's quite poorly
frankly worries me he's here is he going
to class - what's that is he going to
the class - he's going to be a week
after next his house after that he takes
them - until then okay well it's online
you've got a membership so he needs to
go ahead and take the look at the lesson
that you've been to so he doesn't get
behind because this idea that you are
the only grown-up in the house ends
today thank you Dave I appreciate that
yeah you guys work together on this you
can do it what's your household income -
106 and his is flexible it changes on a
weekly basis depending upon how many
hours he works okay so I'm sorry why in
the world what somebody making $200,000
a year don't think they can make
progress with money nobody's ever taught
me how to do it honestly but the
concepts that I'm learning in your
classes no it's it's kind of like
somebody just gave you a brand-new
Ferrari and nobody ever gave you driving
lessons and so it scared the crap out of
you that's exactly correct okay I got it
that makes sense it's very powerful
stuff this money especially when you got
200 grand a year coming in I mean that's
not that you can drive you can drive off
into a serious ditch with 200 grand so
good how much debt you got about 150 but
I'm hoping those will be forgiven after
three or four more years of public
service I doubt it
no I'm serious
thirty thousand people have applied for
public service loan forgiveness 96
people have gotten it so far oh yeah
it's not going real well this the
government is not following through on
that so you might get it I don't know
you're three to four more years before
you get there and you make 200 right now
I probably just pay the student loans
off and be done with it how much debt if
you gotta knock out in your house
not counting the house we have about
between I'm still in the process of
tabulating it for class but we have
between 50 and 60 of consumer debt and a
couple of vehicle loan
okay so 50 60 plus car plus student
loans I think 50 60 plus student loans
plus house all the cars are included in
the student in the 50 to 60 correct okay
all right so let's just kind of do some
quick math for a second all right you
make two hundred thousand dollars a year
you've got two hundred ten thousand
dollars worth of debt okay okay
210 divided by three is what you have to
do the math for you that's why I want on
you 21 divided by 3 is 7 seven seventy
thousand okay three years 70,000 you're
on two percent debt free and I count in
your house student loans cars and
everything okay well but I think that's
kind of won't be I think it'll do it
faster than that okay I'll do whatever
you say
well listen if you if let's just pretend
that you may turn a thousand dollars a
year and you lived on 95 that give you a
hundred and five right yeah my counting
taxes some using round numbers here but
a hundred and five a year for two years
would be 210 wouldn't it so between two
and three years I want you out of that
and what your husband lined up in
helping you do this you can do this
you're gonna you're gonna be amazing
she's got an amazing income you're not
dumb people dumb people don't make that
kind of money well done this is the Dave
Ramsey show